whether i'm doing a simple sponge cake
or make an elaborate tart
i want my bacon to be the best it can be
so i always start with the best
ingredients i can find
knowledge is crucial the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from
and how they produce the better
[Applause]
[Music]
flour to get the low down on one of the
key ingredients to brilliant baking
it always pays to ask an expert and if
there's one man who can really rise to
the occasion
it's professional miller mark able doing
a job like this means that you end up
thinking and living a flower if that's
obsession i'm obsessed
[Music]
at his mill which has stood in norfolk
since 1835
mark uses traditional stones to grind
his flower so he really knows his stuff
[Music]
what actually comes off the field is
something like this
still husked still needs to be processed
before we can actually mill it
we then clean down to something like
this which
is ready to be milled
[Music]
all this is a great big machine which
means you don't have to do it by hand
rather than try and improve its
performance by adding additional
chemicals
what we're trying to do is mill it in
the best way to get that performance
from it
[Music]
if you can put a seed in between stones
you can make flour out of it
it's that simple barley was what was
traditionally used
to make braid for people to live off
oats
can be used as well and of course good
old spelt the great grandmother of
modern wheats
which has the most fantastic flavor and
is
because of its primitive nature the
proteins in it are simpler so a lot of
people can eat that
they can't eat modern weight keep your
eyes on the shelves look and see what is
there
and if something strikes you as being
potentially interesting
then get it and try it mix your own
blend your hand together so that you can
get the flavor that you want with the
performance that you want
[Music]
mark's right different flowers perform
and taste wildly different
and so they're well worth trying out
here's my quick guide to some of the
flowers
i like using
strong flour is the one to choose for
standard bread making the higher the
protein content the crust your loaf will
be
the flour hailing from italy double zero
it's super finely milled
and perfect for pasta i like to use it
for pizzas too because it produces a
nice crispy crust like the one on my
mozzarella and rosemary version
rye flour will give you really dense
fruity flavored bread
fruit cakes or scones if it's too heavy
for you just mix it with standard wheat
flour
and when you are baking remember that
self-raising flour is just plain flour
with raisin asians added so if you run
out you can add baking powder
and salt to your plain flour and get
baking
that's the real stuff that's it fresh
flour straight out the mill
is so superior in flavor and performance
that
uh it's only when you come to use it you
realise what the difference is
if you're going to experiment with
ingredients in bacon you still need to
follow some basic rules to make sure
things turn out brilliantly every time
kicking off with my simple soda bread
first up measure out your dry
ingredients plain flour
wholemeal flour
salt sugar
and bicarbonate of soda
[Music]
mix get 450 ml of buttermilk
pour most of it in and combined
buttermilk has a wonderful subtle sour
note that gives this bread a deliciously
different taste
you can get it in most of the big
supermarkets
if your dough's a bit stiff add the rest
of your buttermilk
flour your board gently knead the
mixture for about 30 seconds until it's
all combined
dust your baking tray place your dough
in the center
and score a deep cross with a knife to
get a perfect crust
then simply bake in a preheated oven for
30 to 35 minutes
amazingly easy absolutely delicious and
foolproof
hot crusty homemade soda bread whenever
you want
my next no sweat bread recipe is even
faster to make
quick flatbreads with lemon thyme and
ricotta
for the dough mix first slice a leek
lengthwise and chop
and saute in a pan with olive oil and
butter till tender
season next combine flour with a pinch
of seasoning
and olive oil and mix in your cooked
leeks
bring the dough together in a bowl with
a drop of warm water
cover and rest for 20 minutes allowing
the dough mixture to relax
means the resulting bread will be nice
and soft
then dust the dough with flour mold into
a sausage shape
slice it into rounds
[Music]
and flatten with a rolling pin
then simply fry in a hot dry pan
[Music]
when golden and crisp on each side
remove
for a simple supper served with a
cottage cheese
lemon zest and fresh thyme
so simple so fast and so versatile
flatbreads to die for next
how to make one of the world's most
popular bread-based foods fast
mozzarella and rosemary pizza
[Music]
for the pizza dough add yeast to warm
water
put in a tablespoon of sugar and leave
to one side
in a separate bowl add sieve flour
make a well and add your olive oil and
yeast mixture
get your hands right in to bring it
together
then knead for about 10 minutes on a
floured surface
until even and smooth put back
into the bowl cover and leave in a warm
place to prove
once it's roughly doubled in size knock
any excess air out
[Music]
place back on your surface divide your
dough into four balls
and simply flatten
add olive oil to a hot pan and put in
the pizza dough
pizza is usually cooked in a seriously
hot oven but this pan cook method works
brilliantly
as the dough starts to bubble and the
base turns golden spoon over tomato
passata
which is sift tomatoes
and tear in chunks of mozzarella
then simply transfer to a hot grill
until golden and bubbly
finished with fresh rosemary i love this
classic combination
but you can easily adapt it and add your
own favorite topping for a perfect pizza
in minutes
so simple so fast so irresistible three
recipes they'll change the way you think
about homemade bread forever
beautiful sponge with fresh ginger bacon
is part chemistry
part imagination but you've got to rely
on the rules for great results
the only time you'll see me reaching for
the scales
first off eggs sugar butter and when i
say
weigh out the ingredients it does
literally mean way out
to the final gram 175
now 175 grams of sugar
that's 350 grams in total cream
the butter and the sugar to get a
delicious light sponge start carefully
on slow speed only speed up as the
butter and sugar really start to cream
together
keep that really nice and light you can
see how it's changed color so important
at the beginning
eggs in give me a little whisk
adding one egg at a time stops the mix
from separating
second egg in
third one in
that's what we're looking for a really
nice sort of light airy 80 texture
now i'm going to flavor the sponge a
little teaspoon
of vanilla extract that perfumes the mix
one teaspoon of baking powder that gives
lightness
175 grams of flour and we're going to
sieve it
a to get rid of any lumps and b to keep
it really nice and fine
175. we're not gonna beat that out we're
just gonna lightly fold that in now
what i'm looking for is a really nice
loose dough
that's looking a little bit too firm so
just a little
splash of milk a couple of tablespoons
that relaxes the mixture down
helps create that nice almost dropping
consistency that's what i want
just starting to drop take a non-stick
loose bottom cake tin
greasy with butter then coat it with
flour to avoid the sponge sticking
just give that a little shake make sure
you get all the rim
now just get the back of the spatula
make sure you've got no peaks
on my sponge to make sure the sponge
bakes nice and evenly
tap the tin a few times to knock out any
air pockets that might have formed in
the mixture
now into the oven bake for 30 to 35
minutes at 180 degrees
as that's cooking prepare the ginger
cream for the center
300ml of cream give that a nice whisk
whisking the cream by hand gives you so
much more control and it's so easy to
over whipped cream
i want that nice light ginger cream in
the center
i don't want it grainy nothing worse
when cream starts to separate
now let's get into that three-quarter
stage a little stiff peaks
stop that for two minutes fresh ginger
now get a really nice large slice of
ginger
smells incredible it's so fragrant
green ginger is like sort of peeling a
potato just take out all those little
dark spots now get your grater
you haven't gotten grater you can chop
the ginger really finely
i've got almost like a puree of ginger
going through
but the juice as well take your knife
and just scrape all that
taste it's incredible
it's fragrant and it's not sweet it's
got a really nice taste
set that in the fridge
[Music]
smells incredible
run a knife around the outside to ensure
the cake doesn't stick to the tin before
turning it out
now get your hands under push up
and out while your cake cools
i'm gonna do like a really nice sweet
chocolate coating
pour 300 mils of double cream into a
saucepan add two tablespoons of golden
syrup to make the top nice and glossy
then whisk chop this up really thinly
so as it melts quickly
50 grams of butter that's gonna give the
chocolate a really nice shine
ball your cream and mix it in
give that a really good stir as the
chocolate the butter melts
it thickens like how shiny that is
so nice to finish something sweet on top
topping done time to build your sponge
cake
look at the halfway mark there and just
gently
slice and really take your time all the
way through
lift
it's delicious that nice big dollop
in the middle don't be stingy they'll be
tight with a cream
another dollop on top spread that
very carefully lift the lid and just sit
there
on top that's why i start off with a
little extra cream in there so i squash
it down the cream just pushes out to the
side
i'm not finished pour the luxurious
chocolate topping over the sponge
be generous and make sure the cake is
coated thoroughly
to give it a gorgeous finish get the
bottom of the ladle and spread
whoa one more
[Music]
whoa you know when to say stop
when something looks that delicious
i just want to dive in there
[Music]
you